odessa feels a bit like home
the atlantic reminds olga strelnik of
her home region along the black sea
she and her family and about a hundred
others fled here to northern spain to
escape the war in
ukraine it's my family so for me it's
more easy because it's beautiful place
and beautiful people and very kind
people in carinia
the town is called carino which means
love or affection in spanish
and that's just what olga and her fellow
refugees experience here
at the traditional sardine festival
they're already part of the community
after just a few months it's not huge
place but
it's a chance to see everybody to say
hello and ask how are you
[Music]
[Applause]
the people of carino and galatia made it
easy for them to settle down and start
new lives
we accept everyone here
carino is a welcoming town and of course
the ukrainians are welcome and respected
here
javier colorado montega from caritas has
been helping however he can for months
and he knows all the newcomers
we could get to know each other a bit
better if they spoke our language better
but that's just a question of time
and the kids are great they really
absorb everything and learn the language
super fast
carino has less than 4 000 residents
many of them are elderly and the town's
population had been shrinking
the young people arriving are a
rejuvenation for us
we are getting more people of working
age
and that rejuvenates the town
olga's and her colleagues feel they have
a bright professional future here
in ukraine they worked for a platform
selling spare car parts
they were in carrino on business when
the war broke out they wanted to expand
their operations to spain
in galicia there are a lot of advantages
because there are people very kind to
other people who would like to start
business here so it's uh it's not the
spain it's like madrid and other cities
and other huge cities we can just came
for i don't know one year and take money
from the market and go away we would
like to build
very huge business here
today they're visiting their new office
spaces for the first time
it's a welcome distraction from the war
back at home and their fear for their
loved ones
their ukrainian colleague magdalena
spock can relate she's been living in
carina for many years and she's put
dozens of people in touch with locals
i move around the different there's a
big difference between refugees and
migrants
migrants leave their country because
they want to
they want to
they plan things and decide where to
live
returned to ukraine after the war broke
out she had to fetch her children 16
year old gordee and nine year old agata
at the border to romania to bring them
to safety
it was very badness feeling
because i have seen a lot of people in
the line
but i'm so afraid for my children
[Music]
her ex-husband stayed behind and her
mother is still in odessa too they talk
to each other several times a day
you can explain how you feel now and
nobody say okay i'm normal
you can explain that i'm sad i miss
i'm feeling not good or i'm now it's
equip it's
i'm glad that i'm new
to seeing new people and something like
this so
all most things now is not formal
because you understand that it's this
day can be the last
after escaping the war the newcomers
want to get back to work
their digital business is helping create
jobs in the spanish town
plus the cafe they fixed up has now
become a meeting point for young and old
i think we have no chance to survive
without this help because we just come
with either one luggage and and that's
all
we need young people who want to
kick-start the local economy
and fill up the schools
everyone has given it their best
and that honors the name of our town
some young ukrainians want to remain in
carino after the war
others would like to return home at some
point
even so
spain's little odessa will have a place
in their hearts